hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
at the beginning of part three of his
work on the basis of morality arthur
schopenhauer
is going to consider some skeptical
objections to morality namely the idea
that there is anything
like a
natural basis for morality in us human
beings and the way that he presents it
you know it looks pretty bad he actually
brings up a skeptic uh you know sexist
empiricus and the pyronians so this has
an ancient pedigree you could say this
doctrine that everything is essentially
by convention or institution rather than
having some sort of basis that we can
access easily and he also brings up a
historical perspective at the beginning
saying might it not follow from a
retrospective glance at the vain
attempts to find a sure basis of morals
for more than 2000 years that there is
no
natural morality at all that is
independent
of human institution and he says on the
contrary might it not be inferred that
this is nothing but an artificial
product a means invented for what for
the better restraint for holding people
back of the selfish and wicked human
race and that accordingly without the
support of positive
religions it would fail since it had no
internal credentials and no natural
basis so he's presenting a significant
problem here in the 19th century if we
look back we see that history is
littered with all sorts of attempts to
provide
a natural basis for morality many of
which contradict each other
maybe there is no such thing maybe it is
just a artificial product something
that ultimately reduces to power
or force or the workings of one set of
people against others or delusions and
ideology
and he goes on and he says
justice and the police cannot suffice
everywhere there are offenses whose
discovery is too difficult civil law can
at most enforce justice but not
philanthropy and beneficence since here
everyone would like to be the passive
part everyone would like to receive
these and no one the active and then he
says this has given rise to the idea and
we see this even today by some people
right
that uh morality rests solely on
religion both have the same aim of being
the complement to the necessary
inadequacy of legislation and the
machinery of the state so we'd have like
the realm of power the state hopefully
trying to make things the best for
everybody involved in it we have
religion over here and then we've got
morality this sort of bastard child
roaming around you know maybe
restraining bad human impulses maybe not
and so
he's going to point out that you know if
we look at human beings
we actually have to be realistic about
this he says we should be greatly and
childishly mistaken if we thought that
all of the just and lawful acts of
mankind had a moral origin now he's not
denying that these acts can in fact be
just you can
give people what you've committed to you
can apportion resources or burdens
fairly right that can be in the action
itself but the question is
what's motivating you
and he says the relation between justice
is practiced by human beings and genuine
honesty
of heart
is analogous to that between expressions
of politeness
and love of one's neighbor so what we
have here is
justice and
politeness which can also include
philanthropy in the sort of formal
external sense giving people things you
know you're nice to your neighbors
but that doesn't mean that you actually
care about them at all that doesn't mean
that you want the best for them it might
be that you're actually engaging in
something a bit self-serving and he says
that a sign of this
is the fact that there's a deep
indignation ready to turn into the most
furious anger
roused at the slightest hint of a
suspicion in this direction what's the
suspicion in this direction that
somebody is not really what they're
pretending to be
and then he says only the inexperienced
simpleton will take all of this for pure
coin
and for the effect of a tender moral
feeling or sentiment or
conscience in reality
universal honesty and uprightness as
practiced in human intercourse rest on
he says two external necessities the
reason why people behave morally for the
most part is not because they have that
as their motivational structure
recognizing the good in itself you know
honesty when we say honesty we should
think back to an earlier conception of
it in latin honestum which is like the
greek cologne meaning the good the
beautiful what it is that we value what
has intrinsic value schopenhauer is
saying
nah we know that in a lot of cases
people talk a good talk and they'll even
behave morally but they really have
other motives for doing this and so one
of these is this external
force uh the order of law which he says
protects
everybody uh the rights of everyone uh
here everyone's rights are protected by
public authority so that's that's one
thing you don't want to get in trouble
for breaking the law
and then the necessity of maintaining
a good name though he says the
recognized necessity of a good name or
civil honor for making one's way in the
world and you might think of this as how
to be successful or you might think
about this as security how to just hold
on to what you've actually got and and
tropenowar thinks that most people
in most places at most times
this is really what's motivating them
and so he says everybody's steps are
under the supervision of public opinion
um you know it never forgives a single
false step if you steal once you're
going to have your honesty and integrity
impugned and you'll be you know on the
outs with society
then he brings up a very interesting
point about property and here he makes
some really great observations not
completely unique of course
but he says that
here we go
property the central point in human life
on which life's energy and activity
mainly turn
assuming that purely ethical motives to
honesty and integrity exist they can for
the most part be applied to civil
possessions only in a very roundabout
way why well you know it was quite
popular at the time to make appeals as
some people still do today to like a
natural right to property you know and
say that property is essentially like an
extension of the human being who has it
and you've got to keep your hands off of
other people's property or else you're
you're a bad person and the society can
turn against you and he brings up a you
know really
central problem here he says what a
distance there is in most cases between
our civil possession what we actually
have
and that original source of the natural
right of property the connection between
them is often difficult and even
impossible to demonstrate are we in this
sort of lock-in state of nature where we
mix our labor with natural resources or
things that we've previously bought and
then we generate property schopenhauer
says no that's not the way it actually
works
why
our property is inherited acquired
through marriage one at a lottery or if
not in this way is still not acquired by
our own work by the sweat of our brow
but through cunning cunning thoughts and
bright ideas and speculation with stocks
and shares for example in fact it is
sometimes acquired through stupid ideas
which have by means of chance been
crowned or glorified by the deus aventis
right the god of the the uh happening
and um i think he's quite right
property is rather arbitrary and he says
only in the smallest number of cases is
property really the fruit of actual
labor and effort
even then this work is often only
mental like that of lawyers doctors
officials and teachers
and he says it needs considerable
culture and education to recognize an
ethical right in the case of these
possessions and accordingly to respect
it from a purely moral perspective so
why do we in fact respect property
rights well because of these things we
don't want to get in trouble and we
don't want to
get a bad reputation
and he talks about how it's so much
easier
for rich people to
follow these rules
and
they can even think of themselves as
truly
moral persons he says the wealthy man is
often of inviolable integrity because he
is wholeheartedly devoted to a rule and
maintains a maximum on whose observance
depend his entire possessions and the
many advantages he thereby
enjoys he there
therefore thoroughly in earnest of his
profession of the fundamental principle
to each their own and never departs from
it and
chopina were saying well of course they
do they benefit from it it's easy for
them it doesn't require any real
sacrifice the poor person on the other
hand the one who
looks at property
and you know sees what they don't have
he says that
the poor man who has come off badly and
by virtue of an inequality of property
sees himself condemned to want and hard
work while others openly and obviously
live in luxury and idleness will hardly
acknowledge that underlying this
inequality is a corresponding inequality
of merit and honest livelihood
but if he doesn't recognize this how is
he to defined the purely ethical impulse
to honesty and uprightness so if we
think about property as a case
study here something that's really
essential to human beings
we're not going to get
that
we just recognize morality and then
follow it kind of automatically
it's easy to be moral for the rich it's
hard to be moral for the poor
it's also easy he says
for the the merchants who are very
invested
in that sort of thing and so um
schopenhauer goes on and says what is
going to keep the poor people in check
what is going to help them what is going
to restrain them right
and so you know one thing that people
talk about is
conscience and this is you know
quite interesting he says in the face of
the skeptical view appeal is made in the
first instance to
conscience
we don't always do that sometimes we
talk about like a moral compass or you
know you just kind of know what the
right thing to do is we bandy about
these words like integrity and honesty
and justice and kindness
but
what's the real case so he says
well first the first problem with with
conscience
is that um
you know
not everybody has
a well-formed conscience uh some people
have good consciences some have bad
consciences right so
that is not actually going to give us
what it is that we're looking for but
what else can we what else can we say
about conscience it's uh got a number
of issues with it he says that
[Music]
the violation of external arbitrary even
absurd rules torments a many a man with
inner reproaches
precisely as does conscience and these
can be like
very arbitrary he gives the example of
jewish people who do something on the
sabbath and then they're they're
bothered by this he also talks about a
nobleman or officer stung by a secret
self-reproach because in the case of
some rebuke he did not properly comply
with the laws of the fool's code called
nightly honor which is this necessity of
a good name right
so
conscience is not actually going to help
us and he's got this great quip here
where he says many a man would be
astonished if he saw how his conscience
which seems to him such an imposing
affair
is really made up where does conscience
come from so he suggests
it probably consists of one fifth fear
of men
one fifth fear of the gods one fifth
prejudice judging ahead of time
literally
one-fifth vanity and one-fifth habit
so
you know what is conscious he says take
religious people religious people of
every faith frequently understand by
conscience nothing but the dogmas and
commandments of their religion
and self-scrutiny undertaken with
reference
to them so conscience is not going to be
particularly
helpful
um where are we going to get a basis of
morality from he's not going to tell us
quite here but he is going to point out
that there are moral people there are
people who do
good things
so it's just as certain that there are
actions of it is just as certain there
are actions of disinterested
philanthropy and of entirely voluntary
justice to appeal not to the facts of
consciousness but simply to experience i
refer to isolated yet indubitable cases
as proofs of such action not until not
only was the danger of legal prosecution
entirely excluded here but that of
discovery and even of suspicion
and yet the rich man was given his
property by the poor for instance
something is lost found in return to the
owner a deposit made to a third party
who has since died is restored to the
rightful owner a sum of money privately
entrusted to a poor man by a fugitive
for whom it is faithfully kept and to
whom it is returned undoubtedly
there are cases of this kind now notice
what he says next
but
the surprise the deep emotion and the
high respect with which we welcome them
are clear evidence
that they belong to things we do not
expect and are
rare exceptions and he goes on to say
yes there are genuinely moral people and
they're like four leaf clovers they
happen but they're not the norm
most people
are not really
acting out of
genuine morality they're acting out of
you know the
want to protect themselves to to advance
themselves and we're going to get to
that in a bit when we look at other
parts of this particularly the
anti-moral incentives that he'll
discuss a little bit later he's going to
say
all these skeptical objections taken
together
certainly do not suffice to deny the
existence
of all genuine morality but
they do
moderate it they moderate our
expectations of the moral tendency
in human beings and consequently of the
natural foundation of ethics and he goes
on and says
for much that is ascribed to this
foundation can be shown to spring from
other motives and a consideration of the
moral depravity of the world proves
clearly enough the incentive to do good
cannot be very powerful especially as it
does not often work even where the
motives opposing it are not
strong right so
whatever genuine basis there's going to
be it's not going to be something that
like automatically convinces people or
is present in everybody
so we really do have to moderate our
claims about
genuine morality and its basis and how
people
follow it and he he talks about
education i think this is something very
very important to think about it's not
just education in schools it's education
in general
formation we could say where we get our
moral ideas from as children and he
points out something
very uh problematic he says
in education people imagine they promote
the morality of the young by
representing uprightness and virtue as
the maxims that are universally observed
in the world now why is that a bad thing
in part because it's false
in part because
realizing that it's false
can lead these children as they become
adults into
a kind of
resourcelessness where they think that
maybe there isn't
any genuine morality he says if later
experience teaches them something
different
often to their great detriment because
they trust other people the discovery
that the teachers of their youth were
from the first to deceive them can have
a more injurious effect on their own
morality than if those teachers
themselves had given the first example
of frankness and honesty and said the
world is sunk in evil men are not what
they ought to be do not let that lead
you astray and see that you
are
better all this as i have said makes it
more difficult for us to recognize the
actual immorality of the human race when
we think that people are better than
they are because we've you know
uncritically bought into lines of
hopeful thinking or bs or ideology
whatever it happens to be that our
teachers give us
and maybe even you could say our
institutions teach us and our culture
teaches us or our parents
teach us
were being set up
for
some serious
issues
he closes out this section
by making a distinction about ethics and
he says that
i'll probably be told ethics is not
concerned with how people
actually behave
but
this is the science that states how they
ought to behave here you can think about
kant for example right
and schopenhauer says
no that's not what ethics is actually
about uh it doesn't um just have to do
with the concept of ought or the
imperative form of ethics which is a
really it has a theological morality and
outside of this it loses sense and
meaning he says i assume on the other
hand the purpose of ethics is to
indicate explain and trace to its
ultimate ground
the extremely varied behavior of human
beings from a moral point of view
there's no other way for discovering the
foundations of ethics than the empirical
namely to investigate whether there are
generally any actions to which we must
attribute genuine moral worth what would
these be he gives three examples
voluntary justice doing justice when you
don't have to right
pure
philanthropy giving to other people
benefiting them without expecting
something in return including praise or
something like that and then he also
says real
magnanimity this capacity to rise above
and not allow yourself to be bothered by
trivial matters
and he thinks that this does exist but
we have to
instead of engaging in a priori
speculation about it or trying to impose
this on everybody or you know buying
into what our educators tell us we need
instead
to look at how people actually are to
how the psychology and motivations of
human beings work so these skeptical
doubts about morality they're useful in
a way
for
leading us to be more realistic
according to schopenhauer but we don't
have to buy into them all together
and say oh it's all just self-interest
or egoism or something like that instead
we need to look
we need to do the work
of looking afar to find instances of
genuine morality and what
motivates it
you